quoi qu'en disent les partisans de
georges tron son mandat présidentiel a
pris fin cette semaine est le principal
intéressé en même fini par le
reconnaître
[Musique]
mais au sein de la base électorale de
donald trump se trouvent les adeptes de
la mouvance conspirationnistes couronne
il avait prophétisé la réélection du
controversé milliardaires qui ne s'est
pas produite le 3 novembre dernier et
l'assermentation de tourbe hayden de
cadres certainement pas avec le plan
contre les élites mondiales échafaudé
par le mystérieux ku désormais très
discret
dans ce contexte comment cette mouvance
vaut faire pour rester en vie
exit donald trump le personnage au
centre des croyances des adeptes d'un k
naan brigitte était de retour ou
décrypteurs précis nous nous aider à y
voir un peu plus clair avec tout ce qui
se passe dans cet univers là mais
commençons avec toi jeff parce que pour
eux pour ces gens là c'est une prophétie
qui ne se concrétisent pas rappel nous
pourquoi les derniers jours constituent
autant un point tournant pour les
adeptes de quang huy belle à la croyance
fondamentale de qmm c'est que le prise
d'empreintes avait été élu pour mettre
en place un vaste plan pour se
débarrasser des éléments indésirables au
sein du gouvernement américain et y met
de l'élite politique mondiale et qu'il
faisait tout simplement attendre le
moment important pour mettre en marche
ce plan la belle mercredi midi joe biden
a été assermenté prises dans les états
unis dans l'autre choc n'est plus
président les prophéties maintenant
impossible selon toute logique qui
voudrait semblables s'adoraient de la
dernière fois qu'on se parle de la
conspiration qui en a nous décryptons
mais bon ça cause beaucoup de remous
dans la communauté qui en a un peu
partout dans le monde on ne vous étonnez
même dans les minutes qui menait à
l'assermentation de joe boyd des gens te
regardent il reste 5 minutes mais le
plan sans vivre vivons l'arrêté ils vont
arrêter tous les politiques sont là
d'une violation
mais quand c'est un fait accompli
certains partisans de cette mouvance le
qui ont cherché bon elle a juste fils
qui venait de se passer donc certaines
personnes qui disaient que
l'assermentation veut tout simplement
pas eu lieu que c'était devant un écran
et que ces gens là n'étaient pas
vraiment capital donc c'est pas vraiment
fils y est les quais dans notre champ
allait revenir en mars
on évite une sorte d' excuses à ces
farfelus ya même des gens qui se sont
remis à dire qu'avec nos matches au bail
d'une fait partie du plan et que c'est
lui qui veulent mettre en marche et que
davantage en plus aux légumes bâton
parce que selon la logique de clown ans
à ce propos que le plan m'arrive pas que
dans notre centre tourne à la vie privée
après ça par contre on a vu beaucoup de
fractures au sein du mouvement donc il
ya des gens qui écoutent et c'est fini
et on s'est fait avoir on s'est fait
berner il ya même urgence
le fils du propriétaire des échos ou qui
publie ces messages qui finalement a dit
ben je jette l'épongé bien vite les
personnes à retourner chez vous il faut
respecter le président et la
constitution et on travaillera sur
d'autres choses
c'est fini mais c'est pas un message qui
fait le consensus o 5 ce mouvement c'est
un message que j'ai trouvé
personnellement très déconcertant y
avait une certaine désinvolture dans
tous les brigitte tout a passé pas mal
de temps à écumer les forums et les
discussions entre les adeptes québécois
de cette mouvance le commis réagissent
mais j'ai suivi les groupes québécois
mais aussi j'ai jeté un coup d'oeil sur
ce qui se passait dans la communauté
mais partout en général et je crois que
quelqu'un sur twitter et vous que
pendant l'inauguration il y avait ce qui
est là ce qu'ils ont appelé claude leys
cette espèce de deux soirs pour une
violence quelconque on souhaitait voir
un coup d'éclat télé gens attendaient
jusqu'à midi voir que quelque chose
allait se passer de lui mais assez
déconcertant de voir que qu'il
souhaitait voir quelque chose arrivait
quelque chose de possiblement violent
l'armée débarque outre homme qui revient
et qu'en ce moment là n'est pas arrivé
le sur les plateformes québécoise qui
sait où et alex que cette gueule qu'est
ce qui se passe
il va nous expliquer et on voyait que
les gens se sentaient il ya eu plusieurs
réactions comme vous le dites ça s'est
fracturée mais il y avait des gens qui
disaient non alexis veut nous l'expliqué
une raison derrière sur le plan va se
poursuivre il y en avait d'autres qu'ils
aient acquis je me sens malade c'est
comme si on s'était fait berné il allait
la réalisation qui s'est peut-être
pauvres et c'était hallucinant voir la
multitude de réactions
finalement alex que cette rondelle a
pris la parole il a dit on se donne du
temps
il ya trop d'incohérences entre les
événements on voyait que lui aussi avait
été complètement déstabilisé qu'ils
croyaient réellement que quelque chose
allait se passer donc les gens il parle
du fait qu'ils ont aliéné toute leur
famille on va pousser leurs proches un
embryon ils ont éclaté leur vie pour
cette croyance là alors le maintenant se
retrouve complètement démunis
complètement déconcertée face à tout ça
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire maintenant
comment se rétablir après tout c'est
vraiment des drames humains dans tous
les jeff toit hier une vidéo qui a capté
ton attention puis qui résume bien la
détresse que vivre certaines personnes
en ce moment certaines personnes qui ont
basculé dans l'univers de kimonos web il
ya une partie en mode homme qui ait
lancé un message à d'en montrer les
temps alors on peut l'écouter en ce
moment je veux juste préciser que le but
n'est pas de se moquer d'elle ou quoi
que ce soit surtout vous montrez
vraiment la détresse psychologique réel
dans lequel sont plongés
beaucoup de gens dans ce mouvement la
visite explique sylvain riss président
l'esprit d'entreprise
ce service fait du cerveau on avait
parié des experts matière de
radicalisation de tout ce phénomène et
de ce qui allait se passer après deux
phénomènes de déradicalisation de départ
ces croyances le et on nous avait dit
qu'il faut vraiment attendre pour en
crue une période où l'obsession avec le
complotisme descend un peu ou que les
ans
les gens désenchantés semblerait qu'on
est dedans ce moment là c'est un moment
extrêmement important pour ce processus
de déradicalisation c'est un moment de
fragilité je dirais chez plusieurs de
ces gens là il faut être compréhensif
d'où je pense pas que c'est il n'y a pas
lieu de se moquer de ces gens il faut
vraiment faire preuve de compassion en
tant que société mais ça pourrait être
le début de deux dans des détricotage
conspirationnistes pour plusieurs
personnes